the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video well
my friends we have another update from
our old friend george rr martin overrun
is not a blog website as a matter of
fact this is a new official announcement
regarding the upcoming release of his
new novel now since he isn't announcing
the release of the wins of winner i'm
not sure how many fans will actually
care about this
either way i will read what he said
because i know i'm not the only one who
will want to add this new history book
to the collection let's see what he said
we're so excited to announce the rise of
the dragon a lavish visual history of
house targaryen the iconic family at the
heart of hbo's new game of thrones
series house of the dragon featuring
over 180 all-new illustrations for those
of you who are wondering what's the
difference from rise of the dragon and
fire and blood think of rise of the
dragon as a deluxe reference book in
which westeros's most infamous family
and their dragons come to life fire and
blood was scribed as a grand maester's
account of events from aegon targaryen's
conquest of westeros through to the
infamous dance of the dragons
the civil war that nearly undid the
targaryen rule
the rise of the dragon will cover the
same time period but it was written in a
more encyclopedic style similar to the
world of ice and fire
in fact the world of ice and fire
authors ilio and linda have returned to
help with this tome
the rise of the dragon is for the fans
who are steeped in the lore of westeros
as well as those meeting the targaryens
for the first time in the hbo series
house of the dragon it will release this
october well i will say it is exciting
to be getting a new book from george rr
martin however we all know this is not
the one we actually want now i certainly
understand why they're releasing it in
fact this release date might even hit it
when we might see house of the dragon
they're obviously releasing this to help
hype up the new show not to mention this
will most likely satisfy the publisher
since he's not done with the winds of
winter i'm interested in seeing all of
the new artwork but other than that i
don't have much else to say about this
announcement let me know what all of you
think down below are you actually
excited for this or does it only make
you even more upset because it's not the
wins of winner
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching the short
update video make sure you subscribe to
stay up to date on any and all news
regarding game of thrones house of the
dragon and a song of ice and fire have a
great day everyone i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
so
you